الآن سنتوجه إلى القاهرة، مصر ريك
برينان، مدير الطوارئ الإقليمي
لمنظمة الصحة العالمية، ريك شكرًا
لك على وجودك معنا مرة
أخرى، شكرًا لك حسنًا،
النظام الصحي في غزة، كما تعلمون، لم يكن رائعًا
قبل الحرب ولكنه كان كثيرًا  أفضل
من لا شيء، لذا فإن استعادة ما كان
موجودًا قبل شهرين أمر واقعي
الآن حتى لو انتهى القتال
تمامًا غدًا في
الواقع جون النظام الصحي
في غزة قبل الصراع أم كان
يعمل بشكل جيد إلى حد معقول أه نظام في
الواقع أه النتائج الصحية أه أنت  تعرف
أه متوسط ​​العمر
المتوقع لوفيات الأطفال وفيات الأمهات
كانت في نطاق متوسط ​​أه
لمنطقة الشرق الأوسط لذلك في ظل
ظروف صعبة للغاية، كما تعلم أن
الطاقم الطبي وطاقم الصحة العامة
أه في غزة كانوا يقومون
بعمل جيد بشكل ملحوظ ولكن كما كنت  أشارت أم أن
النظام قد تدهور بشكل كبير أه
منذ بداية الصراع أه من
36 مستشفى عام عامل وصلنا
الآن إلى 12 أه هناك أربع
مرافق فقط تعمل في الشمال الآن
واحد منهم المستشفى به حوالي
30 سريرًا عاملًا فقط  مستشفى
الصحابة الآخر هو مستشفى للولادة
ويقدم بشكل أساسي الخدمات
للنساء، أما المرفقان الآخران
فيقدمان بشكل أساسي رعاية المرضى الخارجيين،
لذلك انتقلنا من حوالي 3500 سرير
إلى 1400 سرير،
وستظل المرافق المتبقية
ضعيفة للغاية أه  إذا كان هناك أه، فأنت تعرف
المزيد من التصعيد وهجومًا عسكريًا آخر لجيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي،
لذا فنحن الآن
ننظر إلى عدد القتلى يبلغ حوالي 15000،
وذلك وفقًا
لوزارة الصحة التي تسيطر عليها في غزة، لذلك لن
يتم فعل أي شيء إذا استمر هذا الانخفاض في
الخدمات الطبية  والذي بكل المقاييس، كما
تعلمون، يبدو أن الاحتمال B يبدو أن هذا ما
سيحدث، هل سيكون عدد
الموتى حقًا لا شيء الآن،
هناك الآلاف في عداد المفقودين تحت
الأنقاض، كيف نعرف عدد الأشخاص الذين
سيموتون بالفعل بحلول نهاية كل هذا؟
هذا نعم حسنًا الأرقام التي
تقدمها هناك تقديرات للأرقام
التي قُتلت
من خلال أه من خلال أه من خلال
الصراع نفسه أه أه الوفيات المباشرة
من الإصابة حتى تعلم أنه لا يمكننا
أبدًا الحصول على رقم دقيق تمامًا أه
ل  الوفيات من الإصابة أو كما تعلم
من الوفيات من أي سبب في الحرب
ما أه زميلتي مارغريت هاريس التي كنت
تشير إليها سابقًا كانت
العواقب غير المباشرة غير المباشرة
العواقب الصحية للصراع وهي أم
زيادة معدلات أه
الأمراض المعدية بسبب  انهيار
نظام الصحة العامة أه وأيضا
زيادة الوفيات بسبب الأمراض المزمنة
مثل مرض السكري والفشل الكلوي
وارتفاع ضغط الدم وأمراض القلب
لأن الناس لم يعد بإمكانهم
الوصول إلى أه لأدويتهم العادية
ومقدمي الرعاية الصحية لذلك
نحن  قلقون للغاية بشأن
الظروف المكتظة والظروف غير الصحية
التي يعرفها العديد من
الأشخاص القريبين من 1.7 مليون نازح
يعيشون في ظل الوضع آه
لخطر آه كما تعلمون أن تفشي الأمراض على نطاق واسع
مرتفع للغاية، ونحن
نشهد بالفعل زيادة في المعدلات  من أه
تفاقم الموت وتفاقم المرض
والوفاة بسبب الأمراض المزمنة أم
لذا فقد أشارت إلى أن تلك الوفيات غير المباشرة
إذا أردت أه يمكن أن تكون أعلى في
نهاية هذا الصراع من تلك الناجمة
عن الإصابات